they're much thank you thank you all
very much Thank You Lee for that kind
and wonderful introduction you started
by saying we took some rest and have
time for reflection I suspect none will
disagree with that she said I didn't
take enough rest and I allowed too much
interference when we were resting and I
also promised her that we're going to
try and device a life that would give us
a balance between action and reflection
and I was a one who is to advise all
friends we were retiring to be careful
not to become busier retired and they
were working full time and I'm finally
difficult to keep my own advice and it
is really wonderful to be here and none
and i have tried to sort of get back to
the swing of things and normal life try
to walk around incognito is not always
possible sometimes we have succeeded on
one occasion we were in in the coma
region and we went into a shop to buy a
newspaper we spotted a group of men
staring at us and suddenly one of them
broke away and walk straight to me said
echo now I know who you are Morgan
Freeman
may I have an autograph
yes I said sure I signed k Freeman he
was happy and I was happy and true
Italian security people at a distance
Washington said we are also extremely
happy because you are not here only
Morgan Freeman is here and we have no
work to do let me say how delighted I am
to be able to join you here at this
August reunion of alumni in this city of
Paris for most of us at the beginning of
this week all eyes and years were
focused on New York where Columbia put
on one of the best displays and best
examples of academic freedom best
example of freedom of speech exploration
and dialogue and as someone who has had
to talk to all sorts of people listen to
them people that wouldn't have breakfast
with but it was necessary to engage
necessary to engage to reason to tell
them what you disagree about the
opposition and to hear and under try and
understand what makes them tick I think
what happened in New York from where I
stand and said was a wonderful example
and I salute the president for his
courage wisdom and leadership
59 years ago another New York
institution a venerable New York
institution came to Paris to discuss the
new world order her favorite uncle and
husband had attended your law school and
after enduring years of economic
depression and well at Depression and
World War from the White House she found
herself here defending the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights that she had
fought so hard to draft under the
auspices of the fledging United Nations
which is today our best hope for
international cooperation peace and
security in head landmark speech at the
Sorbonne titled the struggle for Human
Rights Eleanor Roosevelt expressed her
wish and addressed a world weary and
worried from totalitarian rule unlike
today Paris at that time bore the rubble
scars of maxi ambition what she
described as the greatest historical
battles between freedom and tyranny the
same could have been said for much of
Europe northern Africa and the former
Soviet Union from them for them and for
Roosevelt the revolutionary cause of
universal human rights had everything to
do with shaken of this history and with
it the oppression of a sternal
state-sponsored power from freedom of
speech and free press freedom of
religion and worship and freedom of
assembly and the right of petition the
right of men to be secure within their
homes and free from unreasonable search
and seizure and from arbitrary arrest
and punish
human rights for hair generation mint
preservation of human freedom for the
individual do you ever stop to wonder
what would have happened if the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
had been declared before the thirties
before the world war would it have
encouraged more people to speak up would
it have given them something to hang
their hats on would we have had motion
there's more role Wallenberg's because
they have some point of reference anyway
I leave you to ponder that question
today's special assembly offers us a
fitting opportunity to take stock of how
far human civilization has come since
September 28 1948 and to consider what
the meaning of and the greatest threats
to Universal rice are today without
question we have taken great strides in
the intervening decade to expand human
rights last spring for example the
International Convention on the Rights
of persons with disabilities which
includes the mentally ill was adopted by
the UN General Assembly it was the
quickest process for the adoption of
such a human rights convention in the
history of the UN and people from around
the world lobbied for it via the
internet and the wealth summit in 2005
solemnly adopted the doctrine of
responsibility to protect meaning that
governments have a responsibility to
protect their citizens their own
citizens from gross and systemic abuse
of their human rights from genocide
ethnic cleansing and abuse of
international humanitarian law but that
is only half of the question
that resolution adopted their
responsibility to protect also places
responsibility on the rest of us it
means we have no excuse to sit back and
do a Latin and claim is an internal
affair of such and such a state some
crimes are so shameful are so disgusting
that they shame all of us and they are
not for attribution each and every one
of us and our governments must ask what
can i do what should we do and that I
think is a really important addition to
the protection of the individual now of
course we have to put it to a test add
to this the UN Declaration of Rights of
Indigenous people with the general
assembly passed less than two weeks ago
couple of weeks ago up to 20 years of
debate today we have two tribunals 14
Yugoslav and Rwanda for war crimes and
there have been some really exciting
games Rwanda tribunal for example was
the first one to come down with a
judgment indicating rig was a war crime
and a weapon in war we also have the
International Criminal Court and of
course recently we saw the elevation of
the Human Rights Commission to that of
the council and hopefully in time it
will be place at par with the Security
Council the Economic and Social Council
and of course the Human Rights Council
reaffirming the belief that in today's
society we build societies on three
pillars and that there can be no
long-term development without security
and there can be no long-term security
without development and both have to be
rooted in the rule of law and respect
for human rights and that any society
that fails to do that will not enjoy the
prosperity and the security it has
even today confronted we and this is how
and I love the you and I was really
pleased that the members generally seem
to have accepted the three pillar
approach yet we must acknowledge despite
these games are there are enormous
challenges which remain with us and in
many ways they are much more daunting as
I speak today we are faced with a
tragedy or therefore we have seen the
brutal repression in miramar against
people who are simply demand in peaceful
and democratic reform the military
should heed the will and the wishes of
the people they cannot stem the tide of
history in my judgment what is happening
is irreversible they are doomed and they
should not compound their own
predicament and I would ask them to
release all political prisoners
including Anson sushi and initiate an
all inclusive dialogue with a programme
of action for return to democratic rule
and I hope they would engage seriously
the envoi that the Security Council and
the Secretary General have sent to me
amar but as I was saying we we are
facing daunting challenges and today the
threats that we face do not necessarily
come from others we as human community
pose the greatest threat to human rights
as a result of our increase in area
alienation from yet unprecedented impact
on not on our natural world as some of
you may know environmental change and
natural disasters already dipped
displays more people than armed conflict
we had ten
lilian East Africans head by floods or
droughts in recent years this year flood
and due to heavy monsoons had affected
estimated 20 million people in South
Asia including 1.6 million in China tens
of thousands of Africans in West Africa
in the Sahel region have lost their
homes and livelihood because of rain and
I must say there is growing consensus
among the scientific community that the
increased severity and frequency of
these extreme events is direct result of
global change and climate woman at the
same time we face an unbearable and
growing gap between extreme wealth and
poverty the situation is urgent there
are 220 million Africans one third of
our population who suffer from hunger
and more than 300 million people south
of the Sahara who live on less than one
dollar a day these twin challenges the
sustainability of our planet and the
well-being of his forest inhabitants are
to me the greatest threats to human rise
today we cannot solve one without the
other both require a revolution in
consciousness and action first let me
turn to mrs. Roosevelt's formulation of
human rights and I would like to add the
following human rights exist not only to
the degree that they are respected by
people in relation with each other or by
governments in relation to their
citizens they also depend on humankind's
relationship with a planet that makes
all of this all of the relationships
possible
second we must give a fuller meaning to
the definition of human rights than the
drafters of the original charger set out
it is no longer enough to protect the
dignity of the human personality by
staying the hand of arbitrary power we
must also advanced human dignity through
robust equitable social and economic
development taken together I believe our
new mantra must be pro poor
pro-environment pro-human rights this is
where I have concentrated my efforts
since leaving the United Nations last
December for example next month with the
support of the Swiss government I will
launch a new global humanitarian forum
in Geneva its primary focus will be to
explore the transformation that
attractive explore and transform the
relationship between poverty the
environment and the individual and of
course the humanitarian response we must
be proactive and embrace the culture of
prevention the forum will look at the
humanitarian impact of climate change as
first priority we will look at
adaptation the scale of action needed to
tackle climate change is gigantic n
request a two-pronged approach first
mitigation action to stem the causes of
climate change such as the reduction of
greenhouse gringas our greenhouse gas
emissions and the second approaches
adaptation we need both concurrently
adaptation I will define as measures to
minimize the consequences of the actual
unexpected changes in
climate how do we moderate a same patch
on lives and livelihoods as you heard
earlier the impact it has happened on
poor communities we should recognize
that climate change is not only an
environmental threat but it is also a
threat to people global prosperity and
global security the mitigation part of
the of the equation i think is well
accepted and it gets lots of attention
from politicians and of course we saw
that in New York recently but the
adaptation by the preventive part they
need to reduce risks I don't think we
are paying that much attention Jane we
need to maintain pressure and encourage
action to minimize the consequences as I
said of actual and expected consequences
of change in climate patterns we need to
reduce vulnerability and increase
resilience of the poor to protect their
livelihoods such as crop failure flux
displacement fresh water shortages etc
we also need to bring partners together
to improve cooperation and coordination
among all the humanitarian actors when
we need to respond including the
military so that we can do better job
are delivering humanitarian aid to our
most vulnerable communities the un-led
the response to the tsunami honestly we
could not have done it without the
military bridges were gone Rose we're
gone they were the only ones with the
military and logistical capacity to get
us there to build bridges to use the
helicopters to move the equipment's that
we needed and yet when the humanitarian
and other actives get together to
discuss response the military are often
not there so we need to get them in from
at the beginning and see how we work
together the private sector
has a role to play they have experienced
capacities that they can share I often
use the example of the coca-cola bottle
how come wherever we travel whichever
village we go to you can find a cook-up
Cola bottle they are able to get them
there but we cannot get a small vial of
vaccines to these villages what can they
teach us how can they work with us share
their logistical expertise with us to
make sure we get these life-saving kids
to children in these villages where they
sell coca-cola I think solvin our
greatest environmental challenges will
over time reduce the frequency and
intensity of natural disasters in the
world which in 10 will reduce the forced
migration of millions of refugees and
this phenomena is going to continue we
will have more environmental refugees
and migrants than we do see ordinary
refugees this is how we can give meaning
to the human rights of home and bodily
security and integrity to follow this
through with action I have taken on the
chairmanship of the Alliance for the
Green Revolution in Africa Africa is the
only continent that has not gone through
a green revolution and the only
continent that cannot feed itself that
has no food security we know what that
kind of revolution did for Asia and
Latin America we are trying to put
forward a uniquely African Green
Revolution which will be headquartered
in Nairobi the Alliance is working
closely with African governments and
others to address poverty of the call
while also improving the health and
vitality of the soil on which our
citizens toy some of you may know the
African soil is the most depleted in the
world today our goal is to dramatically
increase food productivity assure food
security increase incomes and improve
livelihoods of small-scale farmers many
of them are women with the support from
the Rockefeller and Gates Foundation's
the Alliance was lunged has launched
educational programs among these farmers
wide equipping them with new seeds and
other productive and resilient species
this is only the start we also plan to
develop programs are improving the
health of Africa soils a water
management initiative that will help
small-scale farmers get more crop per
drop and implementing key improvements
to facilitate these farmers access to
market information systems crop storage
processing and transportation we would
also work with the African governments
to come up with a light agricultural
policies that will be pro rural
development and pro African farmers we
would seek to increase production by six
percent a year and try to cut food
shortage by 50% into it by 2015 and I
believe the best way to do this is
through education that empowers rather
than imposing solutions on them by
listening to our farmers concerns we
will earn their trust and be able to
teach them that the contradiction they
fear between productivity and
environmentalism is a force a false one
this is a revolution that we will let me
yeah but the way we see it will put
green in people's pockets while also
enriching the greens of the earth on
every front education holds the key
to progress and an understandin you have
demonstrated by your presence here today
in so many numbers like many of you I
have not been a student in a classroom
for a long long time but the test i have
taken in my adult and real life have
yielded some lessons i'm now eager and
willing to share this is the same spirit
that inspired Nelson Mandela to use the
occasion of his 89th birthday this
summer to organize a group of so-called
wizened leaders and he named them elders
I was invited to join I know in the West
the word elder has sometimes negative
connotation means here passe without
energy and probably weak or irrelevant
but in my culture it implies experience
wisdom and understanding of the
environment and the world around you and
so my gray hair has advantages in my
culture and so I was very happy to
accept the title elder which normally
one would want to shy away from and it
includes many illustris people including
one of your professors from ciba Mary
Robinson is one of the elders it does
also include former President Carter and
others our mission is to catalyze
peaceful resolutions to long-standing
conflicts articulate new approaches to
global issues that are or may cause
immense human suffering and finally to
share wisdom by helping to connect
voices all over the world and we will
listen that is where Lennon begins we
will listen
those in power are the ones who must
also listen most that is why as the
chair of the Africa progress panel I
continue to spend considerable energy
lobbying richest countries to live up to
their commitments to increase aid
productive investment and as a kid fair
trade agreement with the poorest
countries and why I will not rest until
all the millennium development goals are
met this requires put in constant
pressure on an incentive before our
governments to do better in representing
all of their people just before I came
here I was in Berlin in Germany where I
chaired this second replenishment
conference for the global the Global
Fund to fight AIDS malaria and
tuberculosis Chancellor Merkel joined me
to open that conference and we were
extremely successful we're able to raise
ten billion dollars to continue our
fight against the three diseases
and for this reason I have also agreed
to chair the committee of the mo ibrahim
price mo ibrahim is an African
businessman perhaps the most successful
one who set up celtel and one of the
early communication enterpreneurs and
sold it for 3.4 billion and has now set
up perhaps the richest prize in the
world which will go to an African leader
who really fought for the welfare of his
people and it aims to encourage
encourage leaders who fully dedicate be
a constitutional tenure of office to
some mountain development challenges of
their countries improving the welfare of
their people and consolidating the
foundations for sustainable development
I hope when the price is given which
would be november this year the focus
will not be on the size of the prize but
that it will lead a very serious
discussion and debate among civil
society with citizens wondering why that
president got it and my president didn't
and what should he do to get it and what
pressure should we put on him to make
sure that at least he is considered it
was for this reason the last year when
we had the world cup in germany i did a
piece saying that I was envious of FIFA
and the World Cup because were once
every four years we all focus on the on
the ball each citizen knows exactly
where his or her team stands what they
did together and why they should be
applauded and I would want to see a
situation where we had similar
competition amongst countries for good
governance respect for human rights and
how that populations discuss it and
debated I think it would be a wonderful
day if we can get there as you can see
I've spent much of my time since leaving
the UN last December focusing on some of
the major issues
and reconnecting with people of my youth
in Africa I'm glad that you've done the
same today by coming here to connect
with people of your youth at Columbia
this is because university communities
are indispensable to every effort I
about lined above not only do they
facilitate exchange between the vets and
often hotly controversial parties but
through their worldwide networks they
serve as gateways of knowledge
partnerships and understanding that is
where you come in you have a responsible
role to play in this interconnected
world of ours let me make a few
suggestions as to how you can get
involved first I will suggest that you
engage the most vulnerable wherever they
are found second help them to organize
so that their voices can be head and
their opportunities expanded third
encourage those with bold innovative
ideas for educating the poor to empower
themselves while also taking
responsibility for the planet we all
share next support cutting edge research
that addresses the sustainability
challenge of our time where there is
silence creates safe spaces for dialogue
much has changed since Alan Arabic
roosevelt took Paris by storm 59 years
ago but in her example if her example
teaches us anything it is that the power
of words the power to communicate a
vision that can be realized in our time
is essential an extraordinary this is
especially true in our era of global
interconnectedness which more than ever
has made us one interdependent world and
that is why if some of us are poor we
are all the poorer if some countries are
unstable we are all less secure if our
planet is sick we are also sick no one
race or no one people can claim to have
done all the work to achieve greater
dignity for human beings mrs. Roosevelt
declared in each generation in each
country there must be a continuation of
the struggle and new steps forward must
be taken since this is a preeminent in
this preeminent field to stand still is
to retreat thank you for inviting me to
discuss our steps forward in the
ceaseless struggle and let us remember
that the challenges we face are not
easily won and we must make up we must
wake up each morning each day determined
to fire them again thank you very much